[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci de répondre
à notre question un nouveau report des
élections régionales est il envisageable
oui tout est envisageable comme aime à
le dire la majorité présidentielle
toutes les options sont sur la table
donc un report comme autre chose alors
ce qui est évidemment embêtant pour le
président la république et le premier
ministre sait que le conseil
scientifique n'a pas joué le jeu il a
décidé de ne pas décider et de faire
comme vous l'avez dit et bien simplement
de renvoyer en touche et de dire c'est
aux politiques de faire un choix
éminemment politique celui de reporter
ou non une élection démocratique et cela
en toute transparence
parce que derrière ce choix de vouloir
reporter une élection il y à un calcul
politique celui de dire eh bien après
l'échec cuisant aux municipales rappelez
vous la république en marche avait fait
2 2% sur des listes où ils étaient
déclarés et bien des régionales ne
s'annonçait pas sous de meilleurs
auspices les ténors de la majorité comme
jean michel blanquer où certains
ministres n'ont pas voulu y aller
sachant que la défaite était assuré au
bout du scrutin et donc cette idée
sanitaire de reporter bien elle est dans
la tête de l'exécutif
hélas le conseil scientifique ne veut
pas jouer la caution est dit c'est à
vous de choisir alors ça va devenir
compliqué parce que en décalant ces
régionales
l'idée si c'est après l'été par exemple
ce serait de couper l'herbe sous le pied
à de nombreux candidats à la
présidentielle qui viendrait de ces
régions on pense aux présidents de
région importants notamment à droite
valérie pécresse laurent wauquiez xavier
bertrand qui vient de se déclarer
candidat eh bien si la campagne ne peut
pas avoir lieu maintenant l'élection ne
peut pas avoir lieu en juin
alors il il leur faudra à tous choisir
l'elysée où la région est là clairement
l'opposition dans l'est région dira que
s'ils se font élire pour ce quelques
mois seulement et pour partir mais pas
quelques semaines et pour partir
immédiatement en campagne pour la
présidentielle
ça ne tiendra pas et c'est une campagne
qui est impossible pour eux donc c'est
un calcul évidemment simple et facile
mais ça ne peut pas marcher comme ça et
là aujourd'hui
exécutif va devoir prendre une décision
qui sera commentée scruter et d'ailleurs
contredite par beaucoup l'opposition
comme d'ailleurs la majorité l air est
menée contre ce report des élections
parce que beaucoup de pays tiennent des
élections même encore heures en temps de
crise sanitaire et au delà de cette
tactique politicienne dont vous parlez
il n'y a pas de derrière une raison
sanitaire quand même évidente à retarder
un scrutin on a en mémoire les élections
municipales notamment vecteurs de
contamination
oui alors on se rappelle tous les
élections de mars injection municipal de
2020 ou les assesseurs d'ailleurs ont
payé un lourd tribut puisque ceux qui
ont dépouillé
certains en sont morts beaucoup ont
attrapé le coc vides à cette occasion
mais le contexte n'est pas le même
aujourd'hui on connaît ce virus on a des
masques on est équipé on a commencé une
campagne de vaccination et si les
objectifs sont tenues 10 millions 20
millions 30 millions de français
vaccinés à partir de l'été alors il n'y
a pas de raison d'annuler pour des
raisons sanitaires ces élections
d'autant plus que à l'époque des
élections municipales il y avait un
rapport qui était sortie en sortie par
l'ap-hp qui disait qu' il y avait
finalement dû très peu de cas qu'ils
avaient été déclarés suite aux élections
municipales
et si il y avait eu des cas c'est parce
que les assesseurs était impliqué dans
la vie politique locale avait fait
campagne et donc avait rencontré
beaucoup de personnes donc le débat il a
eu lieu il n'y a pas de raison de
l'avoir à nouveau sur la raisons
sanitaires
ce serait un aveu d'échec d'ailleurs de
dire que à la fois la campagne de
vaccination n'a pas fonctionné parce que
nous manquons de doses de vaccins que
vous êtes incapable d'organiser la
logistique de cette vaccination
et puis de dire aussi pourquoi la france
ce grand pays 7
grande nation qui est capable de
démocratie est incapable d'organiser des
élections
là où d'autres pays l'ont fait sans
problème je pense plus récemment à
israël qui vient d'organiser des
élections où les malades du coït
pouvaient voter même à l'hôpital on peut
organiser un scrutin il s'agit de
volonté il s'agit aussi un peu
d'organisation logistique
alors c'est vrai quand on voit
l'organisation de la campagne vaccinale
on peut se demander effectivement si
aujourd'hui les responsables au sommet
de l'état sont capables d'organiser une
logistique comme celle d'élections mais
alors là ça pose une question plus
profonde que celle de la vaccination
c'est celle de la démocratie est ce
qu'on est aujourd'hui capable en france
d'organiser des élections
c'est la vraie question qui doit se
poser si on les annuler pour cause de
crise sanitaire
alors la question est plus profonde et
quelles seraient les conséquences d'un
report des élections régionales alors
les conséquences elles sont évidentes
d'abord il y a c'est tout à dans
l'intérêt finalement des modèles mais
cros et de sa majorité
premièrement c'est couper l'herbe sous
le pied comme je le disais à des
candidats qui serait dangereux pour
emmanuel macron lors de l'élection
présidentielle si jamais il se
représentait pour un second mandat
parce qu'il faudra choisir entre la
région où le pays est donc là c'est
gagnant uniquement d'un côté c'est à
dire pour ml mâcon deuxièmement si on
repousse les élections après l'été le
bilan sera beaucoup plus positif pour
emmanuel macron à la fois parce que la
campagne de vaccination aura eu lieu
parce que l'été sera passé par là et
donc le virus aura naturellement baisser
par les conditions climatiques et donc
emma qu'on pourra dire qu'il a été
fantastique dans sa gestion de crise en
faisant oublier le fiasco des masques le
fiasco des tests le fiasco de la
vaccination le fiasco des confinement
des couvre-feux etc etc et en disant que
finalement son action héroïque a été
formidable et que donc il va se
présenter avec un bilan
génial pour lrm qui est par ailleurs
devenue une étiquette plutôt aux
perdantes où les députés de la majorité
essaye de se cacher en fait derrière un
paravent d'une majorité présidentielle
beaucoup plus large et puis
troisièmement c'est créer les conditions
d'une relance parce que le plan de
relance va rentrer en action
le seconde
semestre va permettre de sauver
davantage d'entreprises avec l'argent
magique de l'union européenne et donc de
financer déjà une pré campagne d'
emmanuel macron en disant que l'économie
ne va pas si mal que l'effondrement n'a
pas lieu et que donc il faut lui faire
confiance parce qu'il est un leader
formidable comme tout d'ailleurs les
membres de son parti donc trois raisons
utile pour est mal macron de faire cette
solution du report des élections
mais c'est quand même insupportable la
ficelle est énorme
comment se fait-il qu'en france des
millions de citoyens soient suspendues
au choix d'un seul ça ça s'appelle
l'ancien régime et de mémoire ça s'est
très mal fini plus tôt avec derrière
d'ailleurs un régime difficile et
dangereux après la révolution
donc ce n'est pas souhaitable je crois
qu'il faut remettre au contraire
davantage de démocratie il faudrait que
ces élections aient lieu et ne surtout
pas bousculer les calendriers électoraux
de fêtes de virus parce que ce serait
dangereux pour la démocratie française
merci avec ses poulains pour cette
intervention je rappelle que vous êtes
notre éditorialiste